holiday decorations have taken on a new
life during the pandemic as families
work harder than ever to make the season
merry and bright the trend is fueling
fresh interest in a line of collectibles
they're called mini holiday villages
what they are uh they've been around for
decades but our jamie whack shows us why
these tiny displays
bring out the kid in all of us
the details in this when you get up
close to it are just phenomenal every
building has a light even some of the
accessories for them to say that jeffrey
kirschner goes all out for christmas is
an understatement he begins decorating
in august i'm always
adding and changing things as because
my ocd kicks in and um you know i would
never know you something's not placed
just right it's just a passion and a
love
that passion designing holiday villages
with tiny buildings and accessories made
by the minnesota-based company
department 56
hershner started collecting in the late
80s just became an addiction as you know
you start with one or two and then it
just kind of grows from there
in this case it grew to three or four
hundred items which take multiple rooms
to display this is north pole wow
i can see why the kids have a big
reaction to this he also belongs to a
community of like-minded hobbyists
you've got the ornament maker you've got
the glockenspiel
most of the buildings sell for under two
hundred dollars but thanks to in-demand
pieces no longer in production kirchner
estimates his collection is worth over
one hundred thousand dollars it's never
been about the money for you
still
it's about the nostalgia and being able
to share it and
the love of putting it together
[Music]
i think nostalgia is kind of making a
resurgence
department 56's melinda segers says
nostalgia is in the company's dna
[Music]
original snow village was born after a
group of friends drove to a holiday
dinner at a small country inn they saw
the lights in the windows and christmas
wreaths on the door and the welcome mats
out and they said
this is christmas how do we preserve
this they preserved it in ceramic well
our number one seller is a piece that's
been in the line forever and ever
45 years later a renewed focus on home
life is driving up sales people couldn't
go to grandma's house so they ordered
grandma's house online and set it up in
their village display
offshoots like national lampoon's
christmas vacation are also bringing in
new collectors
[Music]
who can recreate their favorite movie
scenes it'll start as a little thumbnail
sketch each piece begins on paper
it's basically going in and
using the little tool molds are made
from detailed clay models
the final product is fired assembled and
hand painted each building takes up to
six months to complete
villages often get passed from one
generation to the next
in washington connecticut one family's
collection has become the centerpiece
for a town celebration the tiny village
a reflection of the world outside
[Music]
kirschner will once again host open
houses in january the pandemic has
really brought a lot of people closer
together i think that
this year it'll be extra special do you
get nervous when the little kids come up
and they're very excited around this
porcelain actually i it doesn't bother
me because i like to see their faces and
can't put a price on
their feelings and their joy that it
brings
for cbs mornings jamie wax borden town
new jersey
i agree can't put a price on their faces
and expressions i'm in the christmas
spirit now i am i mean two words for a
hand painted yeah wow right and price is
just going up that's for sure for sure